hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John we're gonna watch the day a video
from Jean jeder it's called watch me
it's uh it's called otherworldly it's
one of his short-films we checked out
one of his short films about a month ago
and now he's given us around two over
here
redux en our patreon one of our top
reward tiers is what everybody your
request you must definitely do and put
up on the youtubes so yeah we do a lot
over there a patreon patreon patreon
patreon you know it's funny youtubers
don't talk about their patreon is enough
I think they should start doing it
because it could be very beneficial to
help keeping channels alive and such
harsh times in this reality I don't
think any channel is I watching it hey
trip I know them
there's a luckiest filmmaker in the
world you're a cool guy I just want to
have sexual encounters with fathers all
the same day she met this music together
yourself the title she said the title of
the movie
[Music]
who's interviewing Jean this is a real
documentary Jean dude your weird guy
Jean you are an abstract cat that's what
I've come to the conclusion you write
like an author the way you write anyway
has similar point of views on your last
short film and then this one too with
the choice of dialogue with the abstract
that's a work that John just used
abstract yes totally woods word with the
definition and everything yeah it's not
actually that abstract of a word that
your strange fella you like dealing with
surreal nosov people's relationships I
notice the realness of interaction yeah
it's like the darker side or The
Electric Company show
well that is a really good look on you
just trying to sound out some more
sinister words struck sure structure
lesbian lesbian the commentary on
straight couples and they're not a
commentary on females exploring their
own inner homosexuality this is
interesting with the coda and just
touching on the real-life phenomenon
that I guess this is based on I guess
that can't avoid space on a book gene
Road yeah these accounts are all from
this story of this church I'll say this
and I know it in your last short film we
had issues with the acting and the
acting here is definitely better that's
for sure yeah this was an improvement
this one I thought was more appealing
than your last one
like would your kind of sci-fi sexy
synth babies going on or something or
like a Nine Inch Nails score piece
almost even though the abstract element
is there I did have my questions of wait
a minute if these two met in this
mysterious structure cross paths or some
like universe weird thingy who's
interviewing these two how did they know
these two are the ones who met they
don't even know of each other who they
are yet they're being interviewed and
they're talking to the camera about it
how is this happening exactly you know
like things like that I was a little bit
confused by this is documentary and know
that it was these two who met yet we're
seeing a fictional reenactment with the
same two women in there well they both
just happen to be actresses when they
got approached in the documentary we're
gonna do some reenactments of your
experience so we want to ask people
they're both like I don't know I have a
headshot or is the interview a
reenactment in and of itself you know
that's what I was trying I was just
trying to figure that out I mean it's
funny that they keep talking about
structure yet here I was going what is
the structure
of this otherworldly short-film per say
I'm very curious about your circular
tunnel graphic that keeps popping up
well he works within the twilight zone
John yeah well I was sitting here going
like okay at first I was like hi they're
talking about some kind of feminine
romantic interlude so I'm like is this
some kind of vagina metaphor and then I
was like wait a minute they're talking
about some kind of alien otherworldly no
seriously like he said vagina
ah or is this like the big behind up
sort of thing that you're yeah yeah well
you know you don't be many thing up into
a vagina beam in the world today but in
terms of mood and tone it was definitely
weird and interesting and not
off-putting
because sometimes weird and interesting
is awful yeah I mean I like the
aesthetics I like that you shot this in
black and white I thought the
photography was quite appealing and I
like the black girl and the Asian girl I
know this is uh well I got a biased
recently John and I had her DNA test
done and we're putting together a video
of that it's a long one so we got to
chop that bad boy up but I'll admit a
little spoiler primarily Asian and a
little bit African yeah look at you
killing the game right I feel
represented in your video gene you are
you can star in the sequel to
otherworldly with these two would-be
writer I feel like when people meet me I
act just like an Asian guy and just like
yeah yeah makes total sense that's my
DNA yeah yeah like 8515 breakdown yeah
man we like women with big lips look at
both of them yeah they both got a nice
plushest lips don't they yes they do
they are both attractive I feel like
it's okay to talk about their
attractiveness in this video when we're
so focused on their sexuality in here
yeah I mean it's very what I don't do
that with every video there's a woman
did you doing
yeah calls directed timing there's
nothing there's such intimate little
moments that yeah you do find yourself
titillated yeah echoes I like the world
of they get transported it's like
they're talking about a day and they're
already like holding hands and like
that's a make out and like the hour
there with each other because times
ceases to exist in the normal way when
they're in the structure do you get it
yeah call this the structure the Blake
Snyder beat sheet you call this
otherworldly oh you should call this the
structure well gene dude keep it up man
this has to be based on something else
you like developing or it came up with
or whatever you know there's there's got
to be something more to this this has to
be like a sizzle reel for something much
yeah I've got to do this cinematic
universe of the structure where like
they're a bunch of different ones
eventually and they're all in different
cities and everyone's making out inside
this make out with each other
alien matchmaking scheme they're like
what happens if we put two people in a
very intimate environment for a small
amount of time you know wouldn't
necessarily be in there otherwise what
it's a that's an experiment right there
it's better than probing how'd you
direct these two I'm very curious about
that where's the behind-the-scenes
where's the behind-the-scenes where's
the making of it are you gonna get me
too soon oh I hope not
I hope not I mean gene seems like he
collabs a lot with females so I would
hope he's a respectful guy coming from I
was coming from the angle of you know he
might not be able to pledge to our
patreon yes that would be the most
unfortunate thing is if you let art able
to make human beings are very
self-centered Jon and I believe gene
probably has some short film out there
and I'm very self-centered so you know I
think about genes problems makes me go
well how are his problems gonna affect
my problems yeah yeah so it works anyway
guys you can check out gene Jenner's
YouTube channel or subscribe so you
should subscribe to
just looking at his page he's got some
interesting thumbnails here he's going
for second video called Samantha and
we're just gonna watch it right now
because it's got great thumbnail I do we
need audio math put the audio on
photo shoots are like that was my
personal favor when you've done so far
short sweet straight to the point let me
get straight to the point here you gotta
make more of those dory yeah very open
to interpretation in all seriousness
Jean you're quite a creative dude we've
talked quite a bit as well and keep at
it man I know you got our little letter
that we sent you but keep at it because
strange work like yours deserves to be
seen more we don't get enough weird out
there so thank you for being weird you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell and check
us on patreon we got [ __ ]